[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen und einen
schönen guten abend wünsche ich ihnen
alles wichtige vom sport hat norbert
könig für sie ein paar minuten und wir
schauen auf eine reise die für
schlagzeilen sorgt
bundeskanzler scholz besucht die ukraine
und spricht von unvorstellbarer
grausamkeit russland die ukraine müsse
den status als eu-beitrittskandidat
erhalten
neue nato kampftruppen für die ostflanke
deutschland will sich mit weiteren
bundeswehrsoldaten daran beteiligen
und die kunstwelt mit wieder nach kassel
erste eindrücke von dem start der 15
dokumente
die augen sind heute auf kiew gerichtet
auf den lange diskutierten besuch von
kanzler scholz in der ukraine mit dabei
die staats und regierungschefs
frankreichs rumäniens und italiens ihre
klare aussage die ukraine soll den
status eines eu beitrittskandidaten
bekommen wie das in der eu und
deutschland ankommt darauf schauen wir
gleich zuerst aber dara hassanzadeh über
den tag
es war ein langer anlauf den der
bundeskanzler zu dieser reise genommen
hat es geht im nachtzug nach kiew scholz
makro tragik die europäischen
schwergewichte werden auf klare
ukrainische forderungen treffen mehr
waffen mehr sanktionen gegen russland
und der wunsch
eu-beitrittskandidat zu werden
das ist ein starkes zeichen der
europäischen einigkeit dann alle ukraine
wir wollen über die aktuelle situation
und die zukunft sprechen denn wir wissen
dass die kommenden wochen für uns alle
sehr schwierig werden in kiew pünktlich
zur ankunft von bundeskanzler scholz ein
luft begrüßung in kriegszeiten
weiterreise nach therapien wohnhäuser
inzwischen mahnmale des krieges
eindrücke die nahe gehen und die die
regierungschefs mit in die heutigen
verhandlungen mit zellen ski nehmen
werden
meine damen und herren meine kollegen
und ich sind heute ihr nach kiew
gekommen mit einer klaren botschaft
die ukraine gehören zur europäischen
familie
ein meilenstein auf ihrem voraussetzung
reichen europäischen weg ist der status
eines beitrittskandidaten
deutschland ist für eine positive
entscheidung zugunsten der ukraine
es gibt auch für die republik moldau
auch die anderen staatsgäste hier in
kiew sichern der ukraine ihre
unterstützung auf ihrem weg nach europa
zu
wie kanzler scholz zuvor gesagt hat
hängt in der tat alles von der
zustimmung aller eu mitglieder ab aber
heute bin ich sehr glücklich dass die
regierungschefs dieser länder 100%
unsere kandidatur zum eu-beitritt
unterstützen das ist ein beeindruckendes
ergebnis ein historisches ergebnis für
unser land
einigkeit herrscht über die europäische
zukunft der ukraine
das ringen um waffenlieferungen dürfte
weitergehen auch wenn präsident mal
kommt heute der ukraine weitere schwere
artillerie versprochen hat
ja den besuch verfolgt hat für uns vor
ort johannes hano johannes präsident
selensky hat kanzler scholz ja immer
wieder mangelnde unterstützung
vorgeworfen
wie war denn jetzt die atmosphäre bei
dem treffen
also ich glaub das treffen verlief heute
ungefähr atmosphäre ich so wie sich
präsident alan es geht das vorgestellt
hat der mann hatte dem bundeskanzler
aber auch dem französischen
staatspräsidenten ja immer wieder
vorgeworfen zu zaudern die beziehungen
zwischen russland und der ukraine
auszubalancieren und mann hatte kurz vor
dem gespräch vor dem treffen heute noch
einmal ganz klar gemacht der
bundeskanzler müsse sich mal langsam
positionieren und genau das ist heute
passt geschehen der bundeskanzler hat
von respekt und hochachtung im kampf der
ukrainerin gegen russland gesprochen
sie würden für werte kämpfen die wir
auch in der union der europäischen union
alle vertreten würden und der
französische staatspräsident hat noch
mal ganz klar gemacht dass die ukraine
diesen krieg gewinnen muss dass es kein
diktat frieden seitens russlands geben
darf und dass man alles dafür tun wird
also atmosphärisch war das heute für
präsident der den ski ein großer gewinn
glaube ich es gab ja auch was handfestes
im gepäck stolz tragen macom wollen dass
die ukraine ein eu beitrittskandidat
wird haben sich denn damit jetzt die
erwartung der ukraine an diesen besuch
auch da erfüllt
dafür eins nicht vergessen die ukraine
hat 2014 auf dem majdan für einen
eu-beitritt sozusagen sind die leute auf
die straßen gegangen das war den
menschen hier immer sehr wichtig dass
man eine klare perspektive bekommt die
hat man heute bekommen alle staats und
regierungschefs die heute hier waren
haben gesagt wir stehen hinter euch wir
wollen diesen eu beitritt für euch aber
es wurde auch ganz klar und das hat
bundeskanzler scholz noch mal klar
gemacht dass es nicht so ganz einfach
werden wird und wir können da immer kurz
reinhören was er dem zdf gesagt hat
es wird deutet zunächst mal das hoffnung
auf den weg nach europa für die
bürgerinnen und bürger ganz konkret wird
und natürlich auch viel anstrengung denn
das ist ja kein einfacher so ein sehr
voraussetzung voller weg der auch sehr
lange zeit in anspruch nehmen kann das
weiß sie aber jeder und es geht darum
dass es sich lohnt die anstrengung zu
unternehmen die gesellschaft zu
demokratisieren das was an rechtsfragen
zu lösen es zu lösen
also der wunsch der ukraine in die eu
aufgenommen zu werden der ist riesengroß
und präsident selensky hat es auch die
dann selbst noch mal gesagt wir wissen
dass das nicht einfach wird aber wir
werden alles tun und man spürt eine
gewisse dankbarkeit dass es jetzt ein so
klares bekenntnis dazu gibt die ukraine
mittelfristig zumindest in die eu
aufzunehmen
johannes hano dankeschön und
das interview mit dem kanzler können sie
im heute journal sehen um 22 uhr zudem
haben wir gleich nach dieser sendung ein
zdf spezial zum ukraine besuch für sie
und die reise von scholz und den anderen
staats und regierungschefs wurde
natürlich auch in berlin und brüssel bei
der eu genau beobachtet alexandra vacano
über die reaktion
wird hier in europa mal irgendwann die
ukrainische flagge wehen morgen die
empfehlung der eu kommission ob die
ukraine den kandidatenstatus bekommen
soll entscheiden aber müssen es die
staats- und regierungschefs beim gipfel
in einer woche dafür braucht es
einstimmigkeit die ukraine wissen dass
sie viel noch zu leisten haben um
vollwertiges mitglied der europäischen
union zu werden das heutige signal den
kandidatenstatus zu bekommen ist vor
allem ein politisches signal der
ermutigung ihr gehört zu uns ich bin
überzeugt dass nächsten donnerstag beim
europäischen rat klarer beschluss für
den kandidaten status erreicht wird
bedenken bislang unter anderem aus den
niederlanden
die drei andere koalition parteien sind
nicht begeistert er dagegen aber ich
hoffe doch dass die jetzt sehen wir
können doch jetzt nicht als
als einziges land oder vielleicht
zusammen mit dänemark das ganze
blockieren das geht gar nicht von
brüssel nach berlin kandidatenstatus für
die ukraine aus der opposition heißt es
dazu mich überrascht er dass das signal
so spät kommt dieses signal hätte man
lange vorher geben können aber dass
deutschland und auch frankreich eine
führungsrolle einnehmen in europa und
hier auch für die ukraine eine klare
aussage treffen das ist eigentlich die
normalität die ich erwartet und der
regierungspartner meint das signal ist
wichtig an die ukraine aber auch an
vladimir putin weil das was er hoffte
uns auseinander zu dividieren
das funktioniert nicht im gegenteil die
ukraine ist auf dem weg in den westen
das signal heute aus berlin und brüssel
die ukraine
sie gehört zu europa
da gehen wir nach berlin zwischen
content manager konnte es gab ja viel
kritik an der ukraine politik des kampfs
lassen zu zögerlich in seiner
unterstützung kers zu lange gewartet mit
einer reise ins land konnte er den
kritikern mit diesem besuch jetzt den
wind aus den segeln nehmen ja man muss
sagen nur zum teil denn es gab ja neben
der erwartung einer unterstützung des eu
beitritts der eu-beitrittskandidat uhr
auch noch eine andere große forderung
aus der ukraine aber auch aus
deutschland nämlich die nach der zügigen
lieferung weiterer schwerer waffen vor
allem kampfpanzer und da hat olaf scholz
heute aus sicht der kritiker nicht
geliefert weil er eben keine neuen
zusagen gemacht hat aus der union gab es
dazu schon eine stimme die gesagt hat es
wäre höchste zeit gewesen für eine
zusage jetzt unmittelbar schwere waffen
zu liefern und in diese gelegenheit hat
er eben verstreichen lassen auch aus den
eigenen reihen der koalitionspartner
hatte es im vorfeld stimmen gegeben die
die hoffnung hatten auf ein stärkeres
signal dass es nicht erfolgt also da
wird er sich darauf gefasst machen
müssen dass die innenpolitische debatte
über waffenlieferungen weitergeht
allerdings hat ihm zielinski ja auch den
rücken gestärkt denn er hat sich nach
dem treffen sehr zufrieden geäußert und
hat gesagt er sei insgesamt sehr
zufrieden gewesen mit diesem treffen das
heißt also aus olaf scholz sicht wird
sich allein dafür die reise sicherlich
schon gelohnt haben einschätzung von
trainer manager dankeschön
im donbass in der ost ukraine sind
ukrainische truppen und die
zivilbevölkerung weiterhin schweren
angriffen des russischen militärs
ausgesetzt besonders hart umkämpft ist
immer noch die industriestadt sehr fair
oder netz die ukraine versuchte auch die
einnahme der nachbarstadt lisi charts zu
verhindern die die russen seit wochen
heftig beschießen dabei sollen heute
mehrere zivilistinnen und zivilisten
getötet worden seien sagte
hun 113 des ukraine krieges die nato
will als konsequenz weitere truppen in
ihrer östlichen mitgliedstaaten verlegen
wie genau das aussehen könnte darüber
haben heute die verteidigungsministerin
um minister des militärbündnisses in
brüssel beraten weiteres thema mehr
waffen für die ukraine auch von
deutschland die einzelheiten von ihnen
hat und drei dieser mehrfach
raketenwerfer mit einer reichweite von
80 kilometern wird deutschland die die
ukraine liefern doch zum paket das
gemeinsam mit großbritannien und den usa
geschnürt wird gehören auch raketen
ersatzteile und ausbildung darum dauert
es noch eine weile bis die ukraine davon
profitiert die ausbildung an diesen
mehrfach raketen davon kann im juni
beginnen ende juni beginnen so dass dann
eine lieferung möglich wäre ende juli
anfang august die verteidigungsminister
beugten sich heute über die
neuausrichtung der nato die schon in
zwei wochen von den staats und
regierungschefs verabschiedet werden
soll wir müssen unsere präsenz
fähigkeiten und bereitschaft
substanziell ausbauen das bedeutet mehr
nato kampftruppen an den grenzen um den
osten der allianz zu verstärken
besonders für die nato ostflanke muss
seit russland ukraine in version in
neuen dimensionen gedacht werden in
litauen ist die bundeswehr schon jetzt
mit mindestens 1000 soldaten stationiert
deutschland werde sein engagement
erhöhen verspricht die
bundesverteidigungsministerium
zusätzlich sollen rund 1500 soldaten in
deutschland bereit gehalten werden um
bei bedarf die truppe zu verstärken die
baltischen länder fordern bessere
planung und starke
entscheidungsstrukturen kreises und co
wenn eine krise kommt können wir nicht
warten
es geht nicht nur darum auf das militär
den agieren kann sondern auch ob
politiker die richtigen entscheidungen
zur richtigen zeit treffen
offen ist weiterhin ob wann finnland und
schweden auf dem familienfoto der
allianz dabei sein werden denn die
türkei blockiert den beitritt noch immer
nach der drosselung russischer
gaslieferungen hat auch die
bundesnetzagentur zum energiesparen
aufgerufen agenturchef müller sprach
sich in der rheinischen post für
sparsames heizen aus der staat könne die
rechtlichen vorgaben für vermieter über
20 bis 22 grad mindesttemperatur in
wohnungen vorübergehend absenken
wirtschaftsminister habe sagte jetzt
zähle jede eingesparte kilowattstunde
auch mehr als 30 jahre nach dem
mauerfall sind viele wunden aus der zeit
der sed-herrschaft nicht verheilt
menschen die in der ddr politisch
verfolgung und staatliche willkür
erlebten kämpfen weiter um anerkennung
der erlittenen gesundheitlichen schäden
entschädigung für frühere ddr
zwangsarbeiterinnen und arbeiter durch
westliche firmen forderte heute die
bundesbeauftragte für die opfer der
sed-diktatur henriette de maizière
berichtet konstanze felber ist 25 jahre
alt als sie sich in bulgarien urlaub in
einen mann aus dem westen verliebt sie
wollen zusammenbleiben sie wagt die
flucht und scheitert im frauen zuchthaus
hoheneck kommt sie 22 monaten haft
produziert feind strümpfe für den westen
schwerstarbeit bei 60 grad
mir war klar dass es zwangsarbeiter
wurst gezwungen das zu machen ich musste
dort
strumpfhosen heiß formen ich bin denn da
oft zusammen gebrochen habe kreislauf
schwierigkeiten geprägt und ja dann hat
man ja aufgehoben und mich irgendwie
wieder hingestellt von 1949 bis 89 soll
es mehr als
250.000 politische gefangene in der ddr
gegeben haben für alle bestand
arbeitspflicht viele leiden bis heute
unter den folgen kämpfen mit den
versorgungsämtern um anna kennung ihrer
gesundheitsschäden
verfahren von zehn oder zwölf jahren
sind keine seltenheit auf gutachten
folgen gegengutachten
und schließlich wird sogar in vielen
fällen die glaubwürdigkeit der
betroffenen in frage gestellt die
zwangsarbeit politischer häftlinge für
westdeutsche konzerne müssten konsequent
aufgearbeitet werden es beschämt mich
zutiefst dass im gegensatz zum
schwedischen möbelkonzern ikea bis heute
keines der größeren westdeutschen
unternehmen die von zwangsarbeit
profitiert haben sich dazu bereit
erklärt haben an der unterstützung der
opfer zu beteiligen subke will
gerechtigkeitslücken schließen
aufarbeitung sei keine aufgabe
ostdeutschlands es sei eine
gesamtdeutsche aufgabe
am samstag ist es wieder soweit kassel
verwandelt sich alle fünf jahre zum
mekka für kunstfans die dokumente öffnet
sie gilt als eine der wichtigsten
ausstellungen weltweit werke vergangener
schauen prägen das stadtbild bis heute
zum beispiel der himmelsstürmer vor dem
kasseler hauptbahnhof ein relikt aus dem
jahre 1992 und vergessen auch die 7000
eichen von joseph beuys und die
spitzhacke am ufer der fulda und diesmal
einige kunstwerke der documenta 15
konnte sich peter theißen schon mal
anschauen
ein mann kniet vor dem kasseler
hauptbahnhof kritzelt kritische
botschaften auf den asphalt was ist
gutes was ist schlecht das öl der
documenta künstler dann paloschi möchte
mit seiner kunst auch die ganz normalen
passanten erreichen dass hier soll eine
art zeitung werden sie wird während der
documenta wachsen und den ganzen platz
füllen wir müssen die verrückten männer
auf diesem planeten stoppen ich weiß
zwar nicht wie aber lassen es einfach
was tun ein indonesisches
künstlerkollektiv kuratiert die
documenta 15 alles steht unter dem motto
lobo das indonesische board für eine
reine aus der die überschüsse
solidarisch geteilt werden
das ganze ist ein mechanismus auch ein
experiment wie wir unsere ressourcen
miteinander teilen können
und so sind in kassel vor allem
kollektiver aus aller welt am berg wie
das nest kollektiv aus nairobi
sie werfen uns unseren müll wieder vor
die füße altkleider ballen gut gemeint
aber in kenia haben sie große teile der
einheimischen industrie zerstört
in den 90er hatten wir in kenia noch
zehn oder fünfzehn textilfabriken und
jetzt gerade noch drei oder vier das
zeigt welche auswirkungen die secondhand
ware auf unsere textilindustrie hat
andere künstler gruppen wie brutto arts
aus bangladesch möchten zeigen wie
unsere art des konsums in anderen teilen
der welt zu hunger führen kann längst
ist noch nicht alles fertig hier aber
klar ist schon die dokumente will auch
brücken bauen in die kasseler
bevölkerung schüler dürfen dieses
kunstobjekt mitgestalten nach der
documenta soll die brücke an einer
schule dann als spielplatz
weiterverwendung finden dennoch
nachhaltig will sie sein die größte
kunst schau der welt
und jetzt gehen wir zu einem
tennisturnier in halle in westfalen
norbert und einem profi der die
deutschen fans sie haben beide
begeistert ja allerdings und die haben
ihn im stadion zum sieg getragen so
lautet jedenfalls das fazit von oz
karotte denn nach verlorenem ersten satz
mit der unterstützung des publikums den
erhofften sprung ins viertelfinale
geschafft nach knapp zwei stunden in
drei sätzen gegen den georgier nicolas
was sie lacht viel
er ist ein kölner durch und durch ein
spieler der kämpfen und feiern kann das
beweist oscar orte beim stande von 5 5
im dritten satz als er zwei breakbälle
abwehrte und das wie sogar seinen der
audition gegner imponierte nimmt das
publikum mit auf seine spektakuläre
weise zwar schwierige partie natürlich
viele emotionen dabei zum riesen court
und halle an zu großen deutschen
turniere aber nur glücklich jetzt 1 500
zu stellen ein leichter feder von
basilea spiele beendet ein match mit
denen sich der kölner aus geortet um die
westfälischen herzen gespielt hat
fortsetzung folgt morgen im
viertelfinale gegen den starken großen
narren pacciani
samstag und sonntag bieten wir ihnen
dann das rasenturnier in halle live
hoffentlich auch dann noch mit aus
karotte karla borger und julia sude sind
bei den beachvolleyball
weltmeisterschaften in rom im
achtelfinale ausgeschieden in drei
sätzen gegen das kanadische duo
wilkerson bukovec am ball bleiben
dagegen svenja müller und cinja tillmann
rechts im bild in ihrer ersten komplett
gemeinsamen saison springen sie ins
viertelfinale mit 15 zu 11 im
entscheidungssatz gegen die starken us
amerikanerin terri scannen
und die 37 jährige tanja scholz hat bei
den weltmeisterschaften der para
schwimmerinnen und schwimmer auf madeira
ihre zweite goldmedaille gewonnen nach
gold über 100 meter freistil ist die
einwohnerin auch auf der sprintdistanz
nicht zu schlagen über 50 meter freistil
gewinnt souverän in 38,09 sekunden und
holt sich damit bereits ihre vierte
medaille
bei diesen titelkämpfen
dankeschön arbeit und wir schauen jetzt
noch auf die große hitzewelle im
südwesten europas in teilen spaniens
schwitzen die menschen seit tagen bei
über 40 grad und auch in frankreichs
hauptstadt paris werden
rekordtemperaturen erwartet jede
abkühlung ist hier heute schon
willkommen und soll die extreme hitze
dann am wochenende erreichen
dass die hitze aber keineswegs jeden und
jede trifft erkläre gleich katja horne
fahr und auch wie es mit dem juni wetter
weiter geht das heute schon mal können
sie an diesem abend um 22 uhr sehen mit
christian sievers und im interview mit
dem bundeskanzler morgen begrüßt sie
hier an dieser stelle barbara hahlweg
und jetzt geht es direkt weiter mit
einem zdf spezial zum ukraine besuch auf
der sie
[Musik]
guten abend heute zogen wir die
östlichen mittelgebirge und vor allen
dingen hier über das alpenvorland einige
schauer und gewitter hinweg die reste
von schauer und gewitter lassen jetzt
mehr und mehr nach und von nordwesten
wird es allmählich etwas wolkiger sonst
aber ist es klar und so sinken die
temperaturen zum beispiel in chiemgau am
oberrhein oder auch am main auf 15 grad
sieben grad werden dass in der
lüneburger heide auch in hamburg und im
südlichen niedersachsen morgen liegen
die temperaturen zwischen 25 und 32 grad
und an der nordsee küste wird es
deutlich milder als zuletzt und bis zu
24 grad das liegt daran dass der wind
aus süd dreht allerdings gibt es auch
etwas regen zumindest über sylt und über
nordfriesland viel wird das aber nicht
werden sonst gibt es einige
schleierwolken und am freundlichsten
wird es morgen am oberhalb schon morgen
ist die waldbrandgefahr groß aber am
samstag wird sie besonders extrem sei
die höchste waldbrandgefahrenstufe ist
dann erreicht hier in berlin und
brandenburg auch in teilen von sachsen
sachsen anhalt thüringen in bayern baden
württemberg und in hessen von
aufenthalten in wäldern ist abzuraten
und es wird heiß 38 grad am samstag und
am sonntag beenden dann von nordwesten
regen schauer und gewitter diese turbo
hitze schön ab noch